Well, here we are.
Sounds like the whole rest of the fleet
went down south to Chatham.
We’re sticking close to home though
We started using the stand up rod last
year and it's been pretty lucky for us.
It's a bit different than fighting
a Bluefin with our stationary rods,
but because it's not connected to the boat
while we're hooked
up, we have a lot more control
during the fight.
I’m just going to throw
it in the water.
It's using much lighter weight line.
So when we do hook up, we have to be much
more careful that we don't lose it.
Well, I drove the boat here
and the boys slept.
They got rested up.
Now we're going to switch.
I'm going to leave it
up to the boys to catch a fish,
which I know they can do just fine.
And I'm going to go lay down and hopefully
they'll get me up
screamin with the fish on.
All right. Good luck, guys.
Did you take out our live, herring?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Up. Up up, there he is!
Oh there we go!
We’re on!
Yeah, yeah.
Bell’s day!
Okay, I'll dig it up.
We got a shooter on here
on a stand up
holding the road the whole time.
Well, the other guys took the
big long ride.
And we decided to fish local
and fish the lake here.
And so far it's working out good.
The plans coming together,
you know, you don't have to go 100 miles
to catch tuna fish.
You just need confidence
in fishing in your own backyard
and picking your own tomatoes.
Just like we had hoped guys getting a bite
while I was laying down.
Now all we get to do
is get them in the boat.
We definitely know it’s a tuna,
but we're not too sure.
On size just yet.
got to get a little closer to be sure.
It's another good keeper.
Hopefully it is.
Yeah. It's definitely a challenge.
Fighting it this way.
You really feel it in your legs
with this harness,
but you do get to control the
fish a little bit better.
I feel definitely pretty cool.
All the West Coast guys
do it over in California this way.
So fighting a Bluefin on
the east coast like this.
It's pretty cool if we can land em.
I see him down there
That’s a keeper
Yeah. Definite keeper
Jay back up to him.
He’s turning
his heads towards me.
That right you just focus on
you Jay.
I got this.
Don’t worry we’ll get him.
Good job Joe.
How do you like me now?
Coming over with the gal gaff.
All right, my left side right now.
Removing the harpoon.
I’ll get that out of your left side.
Yeah, I got to.
Jay I don't want to hit you. Yep.
Okay clipped. Yup.
All right. Hang on.
Yeah, it's a big one.
I got him. Yeah.
All right,
Get a hold like this.
This is a nice one.
Hold it.
Yeah.
Good job, guys.
Stuck with the plan
Well done.
Well done, boys.